Man City 2023 versus Chelsea 2012 I
don't think I think it's quite easy for
me you know winning the treble that
means that you've done it on all fronts
you you've been pressed in your own
League obviously we arel were up against
them but their domination in the
Champions League I mean that game
against Leipzig you know what they did
to Dortmund what they did to Real Madrid
if you got a team that's so dominant
they have to go forth on the Chelsea
side of things obviously I don't like
Chelsea but um I think there is a big
luck element in that Chelsea one I mean
you probably would have bet your
mortgage that iron Robin and
Schweinsteiger scored their pens not
saying that you know didn't earn it but
um there was luck even you know the
Torres goal um right place right time uh
for him but I don't know for me I think
it's city all day long I can't I can't I
mean I don't think it's even fair to
compare the two sides for me there's no
there shouldn't even be an argument is
city all day long all right unanimous
will we be honest much more agreeable on
your side aren't we